hey this is a major story very quietly
because it hasn't been covered much in
media and when it's covered its totally
understated as no big deal
Democrats and Republicans are working
together to deregulate banks in a way
that is reminiscent of what led to the
2008 Great Recession and they could be
working on gun safety they could be
working on making sure that the Trump
Russia investigation that Robert Muller
is doing is full and fair they could be
working together Democrats and
Republicans on climate change on getting
everybody some basic level of health
care or thinking about I don't know
universal basic income but instead the
issue that seems to be bringing
Democrats and Republicans together is
figuring out a way to let banks make
more money and the idea here is to
rewrite parts of the 2010 dodd-frank Act
which did some regulation of banks in
response to the 2008 financial crisis
and while not all members of the Senate
support this it's probably going to pass
because about a dozen Democrats do
support it in addition to just about
every if not every Republican the house
has already passed another version of
this that's even more extreme in how it
undoes the 2010 dodd-frank bill so what
would the bill actually do well we've
got a list of the major things that the
bill would do number one it would
increase the bank size threshold for
banks being subject to federal oversight
from fifty billion dollars to two
hundred and fifty billion dollars in
assets and the explanation is that the
way the bill was originally written it
was hurting small banks by over
regulating them so that the new bill
will make it so that banks between 50
and 250 billion in assets would be less
regulated than they have been and there
would also be less oversight from the
Federal Reserve it's basically a sham
right they want you to think that your
local little bank was impacted by this
regulation but I hate to break it to you
the banks that are currently between 50
and 250 billion dollars in assets are
pretty damn big banks like American
Express BB&T SunTrust Bank Key Bank
these are
your little neighborhood banks that were
over regulated as a result of this
number two we would see provisions to
lower anti-discrimination standards and
the way that this new bill would do that
is by raising the number of loans a bank
is allowed to make before it has to
provide discrimination or
non-discrimination in lending data to
oversight agencies who benefits from
that nobody number three this bill will
allow foreign banks to separate American
assets in order to avoid American
regulatory scrutiny and yes they are
trying to sell this by throwing in some
small benefits for tiny banks and credit
unions to make it seem like everybody's
going to benefit it's sort of gonna
equally help banks of all sizes but the
benefit is to the mega banks and also
they're throwing in a few little
consumer protection things but the truth
is this doesn't do away yet anyway
that's another of trumps ideas this
doesn't do away with the CFPB the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau so
again the little things that are being
sprinkled in there are mostly to be able
to paint a more PR friendly picture of
this bill this is one of those areas
where the Republicans and the Democrats
alike mostly agree and are basically
screwing us the Financial Times found
that the banks that stand to gain the
most from this deregulation have been
upping their donations to Democrats in
the Senate I guess they already have all
the Republicans they don't need to up
their donations they're plain and simple
this is not a time to weaken bank
regulations right this is not something
that defends working people
this doesn't propagate more equality
throughout society people defend this as
doing not that much deregulation but
that's the wrong conversation right the
conversation should be why are we doing
any deregulation when there are so many
other things that we could be doing to
actually help people and people will
defend this as I mentioned by saying
David don't worry it doesn't impact the
CFPB that's fine but it's deregulation
that we don't need
it's part of the swamp filling campaign
finance status quo that we should be
vehemently against and that the
president claimed to be against the
sickest part here is the bragging about
bipartisanship they are touting this as
a big bipartisan victory Republicans and
Democrats figuring out a way to work
together woohoo they're able to work
together not surprisingly for the
benefit of an industry that funds their
campaigns and to make changes that will
bring no net gain to the average
consumer it's absolutely disgusting and
I hope that people on our subreddit will
discuss this because it is a really big
issue it's not a sexy sounding or a
salacious or titillating but it's a
major issue and you can find those
discussions at david pakman.com slash
reddit today's program is made possible
in part by futur vittor is a social
forecasting game where you compete with
other players to predict the future and
it's built on the principles of what's
called a prediction market a
scientifically proven way of using the
wisdom of the crowd to create more
accurate predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can check
out my predictions and follow me to get
updates on my profile which is linked to
in the description if you're watching
this on YouTube the tour is a great tool
to find out more about the world improve
your forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecast it's free and it's available on
both Android and I
as well as on web browsers and that's f
UT you you are calm